[Music]
here in this video we will tell you
everything we know about titanis shimu
including his design his powers biology
and most importantly his size let's get
to it so with the newly released toys
and Walmart sweatshirt we can finally
assess the true design of titanis shimu
the ancient Titan starting with the head
shimu has a tortoise like snout which
looks more like a beak than a reptilian
mouth something akin to that of a
Galapagos giant tortoise mixed with that
of a snapping turtle the top of its head
is adorned with a crown of crystalline
spikes which are Reddish blue or even
purplish in coloration it has forward-
facing eyes meaning it has 3D Vision and
can fix its focus on prey items or even
lesser Titans that it wants to devour
and if you look closely it's eyes are
like those of a bird of prey Like an
Eagle meaning it has really great
eyesight its body is elongated yet
robots and muscular it walks primarily
on four legs although it can also stand
on its two feet for intimidation
displays or when fighting it seems to
have a posture of a kodo dragon and a
crocodile but with longer legs meaning
something like a FAS sucus from the
ancient world it can run at fast speeds
and can also serve as a mount for other
Titans namely the SC marking so going to
the legs these four limbs are large and
sorot like well at least for the ties
and the cves looking more like tree
trunks where at the end of the legs it
has sharp dark claws which are more like
those of a kodo dragon in design its
body is fully covered with reptilian
Rocky likee scales which are hard and it
tells us that this Titan is impervious
or resistant to most forms of attack and
could withstand even the atomic breath
of Godzilla the design is delicious
looking with details on The Ridges that
divide its belly and its back starting
from the neck onto its tail and these
ridges are just are composed of scales
and ostaderm like outgrowths now going
to the most intriguing part of the body
of this ancient Titan its dorsal plate
like structures these seem to be
crystalline in nature similar to those
of the evolved pinkzilla of gxk and very
different from the earlier GVK and kotm
Godzilla design they seem to emerge from
the head crown in two distinct rows and
when they reach the back they grow out
of proportions which tells us that this
Titan is pretty old and these crystals
on the back continuously grow and
compete for limited space these crystals
grow on the back and continue to the end
of the tail forming Aizer which is a
part of the body which is similar to
that of an extinct Sosa surus a dinosaur
which also has plates on its back and a
spiky tail ending so that's about all we
can say about its design for now let's
take a look at its size so let's start
with talking a bit about the other Ts
that we already know which walk on four
or more legs firstly the mut female is
90 M or 30 ft tall then we have a bigger
Silla standing around with his many legs
around 341 ft in height then we have the
behemoth at 354 ft tall almost as tall
as Godzilla in its 2014 version form and
then we have methusa measuring 322 ft at
its shoulder but with a mountain on its
back which could push the heights limit
to around 400 ft or 122 M so shimu as an
ancient tan the oldest and the biggest
on four legs would probably stand taller
than a Muto female and around the same
height given its crocodilian posture its
sharp crystalline Dole plates would push
its height to more than behemoths on
four legs but if it stands though on two
legs it would be as tall as Monster
zeroca it has a very lengthy body its
overall length would be the ultimate
metric Tri on its size it will
definitely be longer than Godzilla who
is over 800 ft or 244 M long with its
long tail therefore putting the ancient
Titan close to 1,000 ft or 300 M longer
than even nakika and Tiamat as for its
biology we have no official confirmation
as of now but we can theorize that this
ancient Titan would be hundreds of
thousands maybe even millions of years
old by the looks of it it would be an
apex predator feeding on smaller Titans
and even Kongs it would run pretty fast
and be extremely powerful like a
gigantic polar bear with a tail that
ends in Aizer it could also undergo long
periods of time without food probably
sustaining itself with the hollow Earth
radiation or it could go D and hibernate
as for its powers we have been given
rumors that it has Frost abilities and
the toys showcase its ability as a
frostbite blast which means that its
breath is opposite to that of Godzilla
it can spray or spew out an icy power
that freezes Titans in their
place now as for its personality and
role in the movie that's all but a
mystery to us we can speculate though
that it would not be as evil as the
scaring cuz scaring is a tyrant nor will
it be just another dumb animal cuz you
know an ancient Titan it would be smart
but its presence would definitely be the
cause of a team up between Kong and
Godzilla and plus maybe another famous
Titan because even if the red ape titan
as a scar King can be easily dealt with
by Godzilla and count together it along
with shimu would be a totally different
story now we have come to the end of
this video If you like this and watch
this other one as well and do check out
our channel for other monsterverse
content we might just have things you
haven't seen before like subscribe and
we'll see you in the next video take
care fam